[Music]
genes
genomes and dna these words have slipped
into our daily news cycles and our
awareness
but what they actually mean often
remains unclear
in these lessons we aim to give you not
just the explanation of what a genome is
but a real life perspective on why you
already care about genomics
perhaps in ways you didn't even realize
what is a genome a genome contains all
of the
information that a cell needs to develop
function and reproduce itself
and all the information needed for those
cells to come together to form a person
plant or animal genomes contain an
organism's complete set of genes
and even tinier genetic structures that
help regulate when and how those genes
are used
the ability to regrow a torn ligament
the clues that might predict the onset
of mental illness
the nutritional potential of crops and
even the history of life
itself are all encoded in genomes
genomics is a new science
it tries to understand all the genetic
material that we have
the genes as well as tiny structures
that regulate where a gene is turned on
how active the gene is and how it
contributes to overall function
to begin in genomics everything starts
with dna
dna is the fundamental building block of
all of life
dna is a complex molecule think of dna
as a set of letters that form sentences
and eventually these sentences form
paragraphs and these paragraphs form
whole books
so we have dna and then we have genes
that are made up of pieces of dna and
then as we assemble all the genes
together
we have our book of life the genome
genomics is very much
technology driven we have benefited from
an incredibly fast development of the
technology
the core of genomics lies in sequencing
it has been amazing to watch the
technology develop very rapidly over the
last 30 years
it's not that long ago that we started
with a very very tedious process that
was done in individual labs that took
hours and hours to obtain a sequence of
maybe 20 or 30 nucleotides or pieces of
the dna
now it's possible to sequence an entire
human genome which is three billion such
pieces
in a few hours we've gone through
several forms of technology
and we've also gone through changes in
the organization of the science as a
result
in the early days everything was done in
individual labs
contributing in small amounts to the
sequencing that we were able to analyze
collectively now we are moving more and
more as the technology advances to
centralized facilities with very
expensive equipment that able to handle
large amounts of dna
and perform amazing feats of sequencing
genomics is not just based on sequencing
technology
it has actually spawned a whole other
area which is called bioinformatics
since genomics gathered such huge
amounts of data it's impossible to use
conventional
statistical approaches and general data
organizing approaches to handle it all
as a result we have a new breed of
scientists who is expert in biology
expert in computation and to be able to
bridge the gap and give us the tools we
need to make
sense of the data these scientists
bioinformaticians
are incredibly essential to the whole
genomics enterprise